حضرتك خليني افهم ايه اللي حصل يعني
اشعلت السوشيال ميديا بهذا الفيديو وهذا
الغناء
ليه
[موسيقى]
تصرف لا يليق بمقرئ وشيخ دين مثل حضرتك
ماذا تقول في ذلك يعني كيف تفسر هي صح
مشاعر تلقائيه طبيعيه ولكن الم تفكر في
هذا الامر قبل الفرح او على الاقل عندما
نظرت ورايت بان هناك الكثير من الكاميرات
ممكن ان تاخذ فيديوهات وصور لك
لا لا لانه هو الفرح كان فرح اسري يعني
كان يعني في حدود الاقرباء والجيران ما
كانش الدنيا موسعه يعني دي نمره واحد نمره
اثنين
انا معرفش انه الموضوع ممكن يوصل الى هذا
الحد لانه انا ما كنتش يعني اعرف ان في
كاميرات يعني او حد بيصور او حاجه زي كده
انا تصرفت كانه يعني ده فرحي فرح اخويا
اللي انا مربيه زي في مقام يعني انا في
مقام والده طيب انه والدي متوفي من سنه
ونص وانا باعتبار انا حد تلقائي يعني من
الناس اللي هي يعني بتهزر وبتضحك ووارد ان
هو
كده يعني واحنا كان عندنا يعني الشيخ سيد
مكاوي كان انا ما بضعش مبررات يعني ولكن
كان هناك من قراء القران الكريم انه اللي
هم ضروري ان هم بيتعلموا الموسيقى عشان
يضبطوا بتاع القران ومن القراء اللي كان
بيضرب عود فعلا ومن كان عندنا الشيخ محمد
عمران وعندنا ما هي القراءات ايضا مقامات
شيخ بس عاوز اسالك قبل قبل ما اسالك هي
كلمه واحده انت ندمان دلوقتي
ولا ندمان ندمان انه غنيت وفرح
لا طبعا
يعني
ليه مش مبسوط ما هو فرح اخوك الناس بتقول
انه انت الشيء اللي بيقرا القران
مش انسان مش من حقه يفرح طيب
ولكن يعني انه هو حضرتك لو حضرتك شخصيه
مذيع او شخصيه عامه
وتشوف مثلا حضرتك الناس تراك في فيديو
معين وحضرتك بتهزر او بتعمل موقف معين
الموقف ده انت بتشوف ان هو حق لك بس من
خصوصياتك يعني ده شيء من الخصوصيات اللي
هو بتعمله مع اولادك مع حبايبك ولكن مش
حابب ان كل الناس تشوف حاجه زي كده انا
الفرح نفسه اه الفرح نفسه ده شيء طبيعي
جدا وانا يعني ده حق اخويا او ابني حقه
عليا ان انا ضروري ان انا افرحه وكذا زائد
ان انا من الناس اللي هي تلقائيه في
مشاعرها اللي زي حالاتنا او اللي في
ظروفنا اللي هو مش مبسوط ليه عشان الفيديو
طالع لان اجواء لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات